[Musique]
bonsoir les semaines se suivent mais ne
se ressemblent pas tout
musique littérature et dictionnaires
musique avec confidences le dernier
second album de tilhouse le protégé de
3e dit il voilà l horreur le protéger
sur un titre surprenant et marque un
tournant dans sa carrière
littérature avec de la chair en voyant
deux derniers et second roman de
christophe de sol un cousinage
particulier une histoire qui pourrait se
passer ici ailleurs une histoire mais
les d'effroi et de mystère notre dernier
invité cds nus est elle à 11 livres à
son actif cette année roman deneen
porteuse d'enfance est sorti en mars
mais ce soir on s'attachera à savourer
son lexique réole français créole paru
en décembre dernier culture première
avec jean-paul menad
bonsoir à tous merci d'être avec nous
dans culture première sur réunion 1ère
merci à vous d'être fidèle tous les
jeudis soirs pour ces 45 minutes de
partage et de découverte pour soir
céline huet vous êtes saint pierroise je
twitte saint pierroise mais j'ai
toujours habité au chaudron et puis
ensuite à bagatelle d'accord et je le
disais le lexique français paru en
décembre 2016 éditions orphie 462 part
j'ai un livre qui se vend bien dans
certaines librairies il est déjà épuisée
que vous le dire ah ben oui oui et oui
ça veut dire que ça marche
vous êtes content que ça marche oui je
suis contente mais j'étais au courant
que c'était pisé ben pas partout mais en
tous les cas dans une très grande
librairie de saint denis
il y en a plus je suis allée acheter
ahmadi l'atpu l'appui on va ont
recommandé dans qui veut dire qu'il
marche bien
oui ben apparemment oui comme la commune
à la salle de la halle à d'exemplaires
sortent bien
je pense qu'on a sorti à 1000
exemplaires comme d'habitude et à chaque
fois qu'on a mis l'exemple au 22 août
je sais pas c'est à vous de me dire oui
mais là c'est la première fois que je
suis sur ofi donc
je ne suis pas très au courant des
chiffres d'accord mais dites moi
pourquoi vous changer comme ça des durs
parce que quand je regarde votre
bibliographie vous avez plusieurs
éditeurs vous avez bien lu dire souria
orfi édition réunion pourquoi changer
comme ça tout le temps parce que vous
n'êtes pas satisfaites
ainsi je suis très satisfait mais après
on peut déposer un livre l'éditeur n'est
pas intéressé d'accord nous voilà à
droite et à gauche
c'est en fonction de ces la demande si
on me demande si tu fais ça ben je fais
et puis voilà
alors je vous avoue très franchement que
je ne connaissais pas je vous découvrez
pourtant quand je regarde votre
biographie les l'on meurt elle put donc
mes deux bras réunis en plus tellement
il a fait affaire anglicans les
publications les traductions ou là 11/11
maloya pour la blair cap cap ma mighty
jean autres pontes bizet bisbilles et
carême cause est le premier papa noël et
c'est donc qu'on peut
oui très jour tous les jours là dessus
d'un instant alors dire moi pour que où
l'a voulu fait ça ce lexique ray en
france écrit leur force écrire les
paroles de français oui voilà b puisque
créole français existait déjà
alors oui le dictionnaire d'alarmant
tout ça et moi en fait c'était en 2010
quand jean-françois samlong
d'informations qu'on peut traduire
nouvelles optiques drôme aircal c'est un
gars y'a un texte de ma volume faire un
gaillard traduction aussi est malade on
en compte la lutte en 2010 que déjà
comme l'écrit comme une grippe ou même
écrit facilement me cherche pas à me
crie beau mais là qu'elle a fallu
traduire c'étaient d'autres mots il
fallait chercher et malarone en maître
comptes qui manquait en effet à me
chercher trop matt est en train de
perdre les mots on se bat
voilà un petit rodez rodez dont la
communauté les mots ma communauté
après sa longue et belle note par ordre
alphabétique ça plus ça pour retrouver
comme ça et après finalement comme
défini traduire le texte n'avait à peu
près de deux pages de mots et mariama
mais pourquoi me continuerait pas comme
ça si un jour quelqu'un qui donne au
texte traduit les prix facile il
s'appuie chercher bon alors on a quand
même trois mille cinq cent mille 500
après ma continuer cela avait commencé
donc il faut qu'on y arrive au boutte
count en 2010 soit 10 à deux doigts 2010
à me disant 4 4 ont peu près quatre ans
tous les jours où la pègre gros me
cherche pas à me fait ch mais bon j'ai
cru quand même ballot screen on est
restée tout le temps ouais tout le temps
mais quand on cherchait des fois le
décourager maman données mama la vérité
à peu marre au prix après mon bonne
camarade ism non il faut éviter parce
que les aussies a besoin mais ça faut
pas me garder pour moi quoi vous l'été
aux hiboux hiv oui ah oui parce que
voilà une expression mal à l'onu en
ciblant ces vidéos même abattu en
français bon bah voilà donc ma
découverte du coup ça ne collait pas
peut-être
parce que les mots ont fait la france
est d'avoir un enfant et pas le
contraire
ouais parce que pou fé ressemble à
écouter aussi les des textes des
chansons malades ya beaucoup de libyens
me disais déjà un cruel et s couleurs
partie par exemple town quartier ou d
aller au bout de deux mois tous les
jeunes conscrits violent de katell
écouter un peu donc un palais pas trop
en vinyle mais en face les patrons - la
ville tandis que comme honda punk
hardcore mais musée diao mettre tous les
jours dans le milieu qui me cause pas du
tout français moi cette saison marque
aux français que moi donc me comprenez
par là justement récompensés mais mamie
qmi cause créole collision naturellement
maternelle est normal bon alors bon on
va parler en entier de dictionnaires
parce que l'impossible entre n'a pas le
temps mais voilà par exemple la lamal a
jeté un coup d'oeil de do vale a
découvert comment un dimanche chargé en
créole fait griffer glee ne connais pas
le reconnaître mais on a entendu les
croire alors évidemment les mots sur le
sexe m'explique pas en contact avec les
mots parce que je regarde bien tous les
moments là millions situation
c'est-à-dire m'a fait des phrases pour
le comprendre voilà pour comprendre et
mal traduit aussi donc mais les
bilingues et
par contre les mauges et moi sur le sexe
le sexe ça m'a dit ça il peut vivre tout
ça ça m'a la famille on la croyait
partie à l'époque et surtout cette forme
des nains parquet 1 puisque sacs bilum
oui mais ça m'a tout donné
et puis dans les dictionnaires aussi
parce qu'au départ mal a voulu traduire
un dictionnaire français est la route
mais mal avait vu madame être content
que l'été impossible
on a fait une page fait regarder
seulement parce qu'il est impossible de
traduire et donc après ben mahdi faut
pas faire comme ça il faut me cherche
les mots dans les livres parce que dans
le dictionnaire français la démo que
nous servons pas une empreinte de
correspondance a pas d'équivalence voir
certainement mercuriades par exemple
aurait pas traduire nang est
reconnaissant bon on va trouver un jour
ouais parce que c'est un mot que j'ai
retrouvé dans votre livre testeurs de
sol
bon désolé mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire mais c'était en entrant des
remontrances des remontrances accord ok
voilà alors après bon tabac ces
économies ne sera pas tâche facile à
exécuter à l'école car mon nikon et moi
beaucoup parce que si vous la
phénoménale et amicaux n'est plus un
fait mais pas trop d'accord avec avec
une traduction nena mos def
ouais bon c'est cuit moi ce qui me met
plus tôt pour revue pense plutôt à quoi
elle risque la cuy nom aspe à cuisse et
un profiteur oui oui tandis que quand
c'est à manger cuisse à un art fair est
facile
bana ok tâche facile même bon bon bon
bon voilà
les sages-femmes mesure on l'a noté
pourtant un paquet à huy porté aux nues
si c'est dans ces débats s'est employé
tous les jours titoune ou koné fait en
l'air mais tant les attentes envers la
candidate a dit oui mais tendresse et
les dauphins
on a fait ça pour pas oublier mort par
exemple comment t'es tu en écrire dans
mon petit garçon enfin maintenant un
petit peu plus grand les aime comme ça
mon mouiller iam krabi et samui ayada
cuisine là bas je sais par quoi pourquoi
mal à s'entraîner médias médicaux seuil
des 120 m mais du coup ça y est ça à
diallo fait un dictionnaire aux propos
que ça va nous aider pas michael dit
mouiller a été paré temps de tempête pas
poussant savate après mais bon même y
mettrons pas moi ça va te souviens même
que les piranhas miroir alors lainelle
de deux mots mais ne trouve que des
leviers traduit parce que ces acides et
acidité acide l acidité les grèves alors
les membracides avec du piment font ça
dit fait font saliver pardon manque
pépiements il fait bave la bouche
acidité donc d'aigreur là la patte
exemple du tout car désormais on n'a pas
trouvé ma pas trouvé ça va pas trouver
fallait dire trop réfléchir donc
m'abandonner comme calme y réfléchit
trop 1000 aces et n'a pas beaucoup de
mots n'est pas illustré n en avons les
mots cas inspire amant mais sinon on
essaye de faire un truc matin exemple
tous les maux quand même à bazens
précieux mais souligne en a beaucoup de
souvenirs de dornach exemple par exemple
à noter l'un l'aéroport ont été ré
l'avion il faudrait la viola avant ma m
quand j'étais enfant j'allais cueillir
des petits fruits appelé grande bébé
près de l'aéroport comme un épicier
matisse en héros de green bay côté
terrain l'avion d'accord c'est histoire
vraie a promis sa main notre bassin
boeing j'essaie côté juste à côté alors
zut le mato pesic en français ouais ça
m'a tout d'un texte bakary qui ta boîte
d'un texte gym ou fortunés m'a vite aux
100 g et pendant d'autres trucs aux
siens alors vous disais tu es là là et
céline huet ou autre et tout le temps il
est vrai vous serez tout le temps donald
une année où la 104 livres en même temps
2010 4 mai au nous paraît très content
ou dans la nuit tout pas s'aimer dans
mes me réveille bonniol matin et me
regarde ta télé d'accorder les mêmes
médias qui le réveille matin donc c'est
tout le temps comme en veille depuis
maintenant 2 écrire un truc bas
un peu réveillé à 3h 85
c'est le buzz histoire mais me réveille
on en fait et en plus ce qu'on lève là
tout ce que l'affairé soit le matin des
graines
parce que tu exprimes effacé sans la
littérature toujours commencer un book
écrit une chanson une fois deux fois
trois fois dix fois jusqu'à temps qu'il
estime que les banques en des bonbons ne
savent pas une enquête à textes bollée
pas dit et il saura peut-être jamais dit
est donc là on n'a pas tous là
alors après tout alors musée en 2010
bises et bizzbee traduit par dalo nage
et chamaillage way lui dire elle est
nominée pour le prix rfo hockey du livre
carême cause et flanker sourya édition
2010 le premier papa noël compte
éditions udir 2010 fait beaucoup après
2015 2 harlow au catalogue de mots
france écrit un grand diable à face
alors éditions 2015 toujours 2016 de le
lexique sort enfin 2016 et début premier
trimestre 2010 est elle sort nénène
porteuse d'enfance - pourquoi dire ça de
la rencontre oui mais les sens il a en
pour le salon du livre à paris là mais
ça c'est un recueil collectif la catho
tu es là dedans chacun écrit deux textes
en français n'a donné que c'est vrai
monique merabet et isabelle hoarau payet
et moi d'accord et donc le livre vient
le temps il prend l'avion y arrivent ici
avant d'arriver ici sinon ils trouvent
eux ne pensent pas à 12h05 meilleures
librairies
non parce qu'il paraît enfin les sorties
le 22 mars à hossegor
donc ouais mais là on va les trucs qui
sont là mais ça n'en a longtemps nous
les dessus oui donc immédiatement mais
on s'entend quand nathalie vous la avril
mais non mais en octobre sûrement en
octobre à des loups octobre bon enfin
bon j'ai pas mal de les laisser seuls
c'est des histoires que l'était la halle
à travailler depuis un bout de temps
pour une relation si cela ne veut pas
dire moi écrit zahia soit il sort demain
mais maintenant quand beaucoup de textes
les déjà prêts à prix bas s'ils me
trouve quelqu'un me trouvais n'existe
urbain il sent que ça préfère la poésie
et la prose c'est qu'on est différent
sans les débats quand même la poésie
montre incapable de faire poème un
besoin d'un homme ce cas pas incapable
de peut-être de créer une chanson parce
que c'est ça même mois les gens qui
écrit comme c'était comme quelques
passes et des poèmes mais ouf et toutes
enterrées ou non fait d'être con tout
fait non la poésie fait pas s'il me fait
quand même causé ces
c'est un livre un recueil de poésie à 77
texte dans un créole et 77 metex mail
écrit sur 20 ans une période de 20 ans
mais pour les pas de différence en
poésie et prose peau et peut-être sur la
forme mais les deux formations fonnkèr
d'accord ok et ben voilà au moins la
réponse
les données merci céline huet qu'elle
appelle le nom de autoliv le lexique
réole français créole de cds nus elle
parut donc aux éditions orphie culture
première avec jean-paul mais là dessus
[Musique]
où
tous
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors contrairement à ce que vous
pourriez croire ce n'est pas un morceau
domaine du sud
mais le premier titre du second du
troisième album de ti l'une parue le
mois dernier lui titre aussi surprenants
les uns que les autres albums entre
diversité des traditions pour sortir les
mouchoirs je ne vois que ça se passait
comme ça c'est plus mais comme tout
l'album août et humaine à un changement
complet de cette maladie en diversité
des traditions rami se voir les
différents continents effet la réunion
ça me fait un peu d'un appel à fruits un
peu l'europe et la chine
un peu benêt gasconne et surtout mal oui
la cirest la réunion ouverte à mai mois
l'action soit menacée que des iem on a
du lourd c'est à dire même du sien
coincé bank tunis méchant tu es aussi
qui peu avant j'ai aussi un album qui
venait couleurs album voilà la chance on
a l'impression aux commandes à penser
lorsqu'on a entendu ça le morceau midi
par un appel à management d'un viagra
moon lui la wii mais manquèrent pas chez
moi parce que c'est donc tout ça lance à
ses habitants ah oui musée je suis vice
et voilà c'est tonton grand emprunt
c'est tout
tous après on apprenait que l'on écoute
et oui la chance quand on fait la sieste
prix chez un grand délire relationnel
sens basse et des personnels notez cause
de charlotte sur tout et pour tout trois
cabanes des causes parti communiste
contre 50 mg à apprendre la prends la
première écoute et voilà on va écouter
alors mise et que donc l'album ses
diversités tradition bien sûr l'un des
morceaux bon les traits maloya médaille
il n'a quand même quelque chose qui n
arrangent mandela travail de coeur d'un
des morceaux créés en richesse le montre
plus quand ils ne voudront pas revenir
mais nenê un super travail derrière et
me trouve que par rapport à aux autres
albums bon les propres même budget reste
maloya traditionnel quantique l'adena 1
afférente plus un mélange voilà ça veut
dire que mon fils était amicale talbot
une cale peau que les pieds directement
les bars et je gagne la ruhr jackson ça
va et était le groupe dahli pour les
phoques bondir c'est les gars qua na
tchuto éviter aux délires ont kiffé la
flûte qui fait qu'on gaz qui fait un pas
que d'instruments et empêchant de 6 et
que j'ai créé le coz que j'ai que j'ai
fini la saison 15 payant ce qui fait le
tour du monde avec tambour tabou sacré
mais suffit pas ça c'est en gaz et ses
fans gaz que lui aussi ancien talipot
qui j'ai gagné ma rose marie barré qui
sur le gallois la c3 trois galas mes
yeux quand coller avec ben métro qu'il
me suis vu l'ours adet crif et salto
arrière sont tous sans fil est quoi
ouais et en sécurité en privant
notamment des apports et l'angola il
propose m'amènent mon texte mais mène
mon mélodies et à un format des
amandiers longmen la lumière et de la
couleur soit dans les bons comme ces
bâtisses qui connaît quelqu'un est fait
et si tu la vois pas ce que dans la voir
mais obliger à prendre man à apprendre à
chanter chez denoël pasqua mediapart
qu'un autre moins bien parce qu'on n'est
pas tout seul à rome il ya pas de notre
mise à part la musique mais pas du tout
on a moins
maintenant moi à lire à comprendre la
chante urnes sur le suspect était un
excellent donc comme el haouès notre
chanson mais des notes non bagués fait
une momie les banques qui jouent à part
moi même mon sens sont décrits dans ma
tête comme ils pensent que les bons la
mède papier je me crée pas comme ça
d'une façon aussi rapide directement sur
pied des monts puissante méchante du
sang lui même à la came oil plus ou
moins bons de commande mais ses papiers
à qui cela l'arrangé valeurs sociétales
posent-elles tous les quatre ans les
conquêtes ensemble tous les cas c'est
une affaire résidence à des fables à
modeler et a pu compter sur le roi ronge
encore et entre autres interroge encore
voilà alors ok houle a voulu donc parle
de des différents continents l'afrique
sera le drame l'inde musicalement mais
le choix des instruments parce que mon
problème on l'apprend le site à parce
que les emblématiques mais on aurait pu
prendre notre instrument aux gars j'aime
la transformant par exemple sur
l'afrique n'en attend pas moins comme on
l'a entendu monsieur attey c'était
l'instrument et mais c'est pas ça c'est
quoi quand même on joue avec lequel ses
homologues anormal de ces instruments
africains
mais oui c'est un goût ni maladie sans
savoir comme quoi on peut tromper mon bb
t et puis comment traiter ressemble
sinophone et c'est pas du cinoche
on voit donc comme quoi mais je le sais
bien que tous inscrits - oui mais bien
sûr que non mais après c'est quand elle
écoute comme ça sont qu'on regarde pas
on regarde pas le texte sous écoute puis
à m'intéresser plus content pour le
livre nous amène à l'est pas ça du tout
oussama partir de votre image ne peux
m'y connais pas paris propose d'écouter
un autre extrait
[Musique]
bon latino doublement sonatel au maloya
bien en afrique où est mon ami tu
persistes et de la chorale a disposé à
vraiment cerner ce mois qui ressemble
loin au rabbin goni voilà maintenant
c'est légal non adaptés au cinéma fin
2005 a valu par contre d'accord auquel
ben voilà bon là il sonne bien
malaga mais le début des quand même
surprenant c'est à dire que corps écoute
comme ça sans savoir que 7 6 12 10 a
chanté o dia thiam qui sonne très
africain à chambon ah oui et puis non
mais wiland les retournant à la réunion
où tu t'en fous et voilà c'est à dire le
l'album est bonne brosseau a fait mesure
là même la peau dont ils vouvoient
musiques extra donc nous amener
doucement doucement la même couleur elle
amy a fait mesure là où découvre cadeau
quand on découvre un peu la musique ou
découvert que le texte voilà enfin musée
on savait tous les maux saute le cdh est
aussi conçue comme ça tous les branchés
conçu comme ça d'un pote d'un coup enfin
monsieur depuis c'est à dire l'entrée
pour l'apéro pour montrer aux problèmes
existants pour le dessert bien robin
prend le temps voici ce que de calories
kutwa on prend les mesures soient dans
le plein en plus en plus ça en plus
saclay étonnant parce que en général
vont semences maloya pratiquement tout
rond tout de suite dedans mais il pèse
tout de suite tandis que là comme oudi
zl un espace réduction des traductions
de préliminaires - camille miceli
musicale et à comprendre sociaux l'asnl
et les partitions là le temps voir de
quoi nous ne tenons pas à eau
voilà où beaucoup de sang mais beaucoup
de morceaux pour nous s'est passé là
qu'on écoute aller mais voilà on pose à
houla show commence l'achat ou doucement
et oui coûte ou écoutent la musique ou
un temple la musique parce que
aujourd'hui préfet entend la musique
c'est boum boum boum quand voilà il y
entend la musique mais écoute puis la
musique conques où la musique c'est le
texte les textes la musique comment et
puis le son qui donne aux américains pas
mal est présent mais malgré ses pneus
donc bosser nombre minimal et yann eliés
ma cinquième pas malade pour la musique
mais l'audience et pompons bon pour moi
aussi j'adore ce boom boom pow musique
accord met un baume surprenant et
apaisant et un bonbon mais tout le monde
les goûts les couleurs voilà c'est pas
mal mais pas mal et moi c'est moi
on ne peut pas les goûts et des couleurs
comédien français a des goûts et des
couleurs
dgo les commandes du burundi pareil même
s'il dit pareillement permettent aussi à
allawi le goût il dit fade
oui le bout la iago l'avant goût avant
l'envoi des goûts des couleurs à bas les
cieux dans le secteur il faudra au rhode
céline huet voter alors troisième
extrait on s'en tienne à l'amour me
donna ou un pied et où pointent carreaux
satie dona ou la roux bayoune irhal
penchard m
me donna ou à pied et ouvre un quart ou
tati dona ou la rumba you hear house
arrest satie dona ou la roux bail ou
irhal pas aux arrêts
elle s'attire dona ou la roux bail ou
irhal pas au sahara m dans l'aval
deux expressions la vie utilisent un ça
qui donne à olaru il râle pas s'arrête
comme on le traduit en français et puis
même plus haut point café prend ha
horreur là où elle traduit ça tu viens
pas moins pour moi le maillot jaune
donne comme ça tu prends comme ça en
france sauf de ce commentaire mais sait
on te donne la main et tu prends le bras
c'est ça c'est ça parce que c'est ça et
puis ça qui donne pas la roue à lorient
2 3 ou la route
les conseilleurs ne sont pas les payeurs
excuses ont besoin de vous c'est aussi
un paradis alain paradis et ça veut dire
que ne pas trop jolie un peu tout autre
comment vois tu vois pas comment tu vois
un peu en faisant de vous un lien montée
au bout en bout ce n'est pas trop tard
voilà pas comme tout bon vieux
catalogues mais voilà premier cd commune
merci c'est pendant combien de temps
pour préparer ben ça se confie dans ce
fait partie 6 2 2 1 2 en deux ans dans
la gestation aussi les détecte la
musique deux ans les textes et là il m'a
brunette de l'année texte est l'arrivée
en cours d'année
[Musique]
selon polly flétri dont il est choisi en
donner pour 8,8 bien possible en tout
cas beau travail de docker personnel est
très sensible au coeur vient bien
écouter les coeurs et me trouve toujours
pas ça voulait dire autant la saga et y
répondre ou chanter réponse d'aig hank
aaron lennon texte est un mot sur canoe
ca aussi les origines à la grande maloya
morceau cas non vraiment je vais
attendre les pièces chantées en quinte
anti à son souci en cela à l'homme était
noyée m'étais fait mais on va finir
puisqu'après donner encore votre
histoire de soldes hier vous n'avez pas
varié proposé au château non un petit
morceau en parcage déjà je peux dire que
moi ce cd dans les coproductions avec ça
qu'il faut les connaître mais mon
producteur aussi que match nul sera
encore hockey et le morceau qu chapelle
et un bisou à halle et l'île-de-ré nous
que le travail soit jaquette nous
dépasserons les 4 joli mais pour moi est
très jolie fée russie alors va chercher
la faute aux lettres révèlent 93 nature
ça suffit là pour la photo a décidé
nains book dessus il y appelle café
photo les deux dans le nord un filin les
notes et non comme ben laden allait
marquer ben laden des blessures mais
jérémy ben laden une série de problèmes
mais alizé à l'être et nommé six mois
jaquette à travailler dessus dans le
champ de recommencer à zéro chaque fois
on est d'accord ok alors informe parce
que thilo nichons toujours forme donc
pour nous asseoir à capella un extrait
de son album fame 20 franc capable sont
la maia
[Musique]
gaia femmes courent à 100 l'entourage
from femmes
enfin petit zinc pour mon bonnet font ça
tous les freins ou sera pas pareil
famille comme deux gouttes et fama aux
femmes sans dégoût fond on s'en doute
goûté mon cabinet n'a le goût forme une
forme amour fameux vente la donne la vie
enfin si t'es pas ou moins nourris pas
bis l'amour forme comme tibhrine à bakou
me pose mouren
[Musique]
fanfan bad jours avec où l'y voit le
jour femmes femmes femmes geste pour moi
car cela moi femme simon maloya massampu
jusqu'à fait noir que tu as première
avec jean-paul malades soit 47 du ca
quinzaine merci at il une longue pause
forme a cappella dans culture première
la chaire en noyant dont nous allons
parler se passe en algérie mais
presspass ailleurs l'algérie un pays qui
commençait à bien dans son premier livre
ode au pardon l'histoire se passe c'est
aussi dans ce pipe
aujourd'hui l'auteur christophe de sol
nous raconte l'histoire extraordinaire
et merveilleuse de deux cousins farès et
lakhdar deux inséparables mais deux
caractères différents
farès le rêveur l'artiste et lakhdar le
citadin à l'intellectuel c'est aussi
l'histoire d'un village celui d'hassi
rennes sans histoire jusqu'au moment où
il va basculer dans l'horreur
exactement alors bonsoir bonsoir
christophe première question bon la
photo qui m'a interpellé
la rto donc c'est de la lave tout temps
cette photo a été prise par un ami qui
s'appelle jean rémy cunault tout un
photographe amateur
il a pris cette photo pendant l'éruption
de septembre 2016 au piton de la
fournaise et le hasard a fait que il est
tombé sur un sur une sorte de
d'étirements de la lave qui a formé ce
visage d'une sorte de de personnage
démoniaque et qui correspond très bien
un de mes personnages dans le livre
parce que jean remy a lu le livre et je
lui ai dit fais moi la photo de
couverture à partir de thé photographie
et il m'a choisi cette photographie
c'est extraordinaire voilà les regarder
et continue ou non donc il correspond au
personnage que j'appelle houari le
l'afghan de tindouf que je l'appelle
dans le livre alors cette photo donc jeu
trouvaille qui tente vous rend cette
gueule ouverte un bo1 celle d'un monstre
et je l'avais marque est donc celle d'un
de vos héros donc c'est de lakhdar plus
et c'est vraiment le sait vraiment
l'anti héros c'est le sait le braconnage
object de l'histoire c'est le monstre
c'est le sait le leader d'un groupe de
rebelles islamistes qui est affreuse
alain frau personnage alors c'est quand
même aussi une belle histoire parce
qu'ils signalent en sorte famille ça
commence bien
c'est l'histoire de deux cousins
exactement deux cousins qui vont être
très très proches l'un de l'autre ils
vont grandir une partie de leur vie vont
ils vont travailler comme comme petits
bergers
et puis ils vont leur vie va ils vont
partir chacun leur cote est à dire que
farès var est au village va continuer à
être dans ce rôle de berger mais farès
est un autodidacte qui a des dons
extraordinaires sur la peinture sur la
sculpture et c'est un homme qui est
complètement nantis d'humanisme et
d'amour pour les autres
lakhdar que départ est un est un enfant
aussi tout aussi merveilleux lui va se
radicaliser
parce qu'il arrivait énormément de
choses dans sept des cygnes noirs
algérienne des années 90 alors je sois
et puis hier
aussi quand même quelque chose de beau
de magnifiques je sais pas comment il
faut appeler c'est c'est magique c'est
merveilleux c'est sais je sais pas quel
nom donner à cette fourrure très bien
aux personnages et aux personnages de ta
gaza c'est ça tu as good as et 1 c'est
en fait mon personnage fantastique le
seul personnage fantastique même s'il ya
dans cette histoire énormément
d'événements qui sont de l'ordre du
mystique
parce que tout est en fait une tout est
en fait une histoire j'ai une collègue
ce matin quand elle a lu ce livre elle
m'a dit en fait ton livre je pourrais
l'appeler du réalisme magique c'est à
dire qu'entre chaque page on passe du
réalisme au fantastique mais c'est quand
même une histoire extrêmement grave qui
assez savez ce qui s'est passé dans
cette décennie noire algérienne c'est en
fait le préambule de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en irak et en syrie
et donc je je je veux montrer que que
c'est vraiment un cancer politique que
l'islamisme dans ce livre là à la voir
va en parler alors je reviens donc à
cette fourrure dont vous écrivez page 26
une courte acheter ne recouvrait plus
que désolé par figé dans le sol or je
passe un fait apprécié se produisit
aussitôt des mouvements semblent émaner
des débris
farès du tout d'un coup un choc et son
prix des fois traversa les siècles
minéraux un souffle de vie avait repris
dans les restes soulier d'une mise rapt
nature et tout au long du dir
cette créature cette fourrure vie à côté
de farès effet vie au même rythme que
lui c'est que lorsque lille et bien elle
se sent bien cette fourrure mais en
revanche lorsque tout ne va pas bien
la fourrure est malade et est tout à
fait en fait cette fourrure c'est
simplement l'allégorie du c'est une
allégorie du génie humain et c'est en
même temps le personnage qui est
complètement
c'est une des facettes de farès c'est
exactement comme le paie les us sont
marianne le bonnet phrygien sur mariale
ces deux éléments à séparables qui
évoque la liberté ce ce serval cette
peau de cerval est en effet une
allégorie du génie humain de la liberté
dans un monde malheureusement devenir
kiki qui tourne mal
alors justement vous en prie tout à
l'heure après les choses se gâtent en
exact à la page 55
le jeune homme était passé du croyant
tolérant fraternelle généreux à l'état
de militants religieux politiques béni
que exactement exactement il et il est
rentré dans dans un mouvement fathi les
sa naïveté je dirais rural qui était à
l'origine pure elle a été complètement
elle s'est radicalisée elle a été
perverti vagues au site est phagocyté
est perverti par un ensemble de gens qui
sont malfaisants
parce que c'est un homme qui à l'origine
aurait été un merveilleux personnage
dans la vie comme farès mais
malheureusement son parcours a pas été
le même
bon il faut expliquer aussi qu'il a été
que ce que son père est mort dans le
livre suit à au fait que que lakhdar et
été emprisonnés mais ce qui est très
important dans ce livre c'est tout
gravite autour de farès parce qu en fait
c'est une transposition d'un grand ami
que j'ai en bretagne qui est peintre et
cet ami travaille toujours dans
l'obscurité
il peint dans l'obscurité peint des
peintures extraordinaires il dit je
recherche l'authenticité de la grotte de
lascaux dont les peintures sont
relativement minérale et j'ai en fait
transposer mon ami philippe dans ce
personnage farès et farès va faire ses
merveilles ses sculptures ses peintures
de mon livre dans les anfractuosités les
plus souterraine de cette terre il ya
quelque chose
il est entre il est à la limite une
sorte d'interface entre le
le bien et le mal entre le monde le
monde du bien le monde du mal
c'est dans un univers un peu par
démoniaque et il veut en sculptant et en
dessinant dans cette grotte il veut
préserver ce que dd odieux personnages
vont détruire mais il va transmettre
aussi exactement il va transmettre ça
c'est dans le livre c'est merveilleux
petits personnages que j'adore car les
petites filles troyat torah et instinct
être adorable c'est mon être c'est
vraiment une pureté
cc c'est l'avenir c'est l'espoir de
l'algérie dans mon livre
elle préserve les traditions elle
préserve ce qui est beau elle va être
dans la continuité dans le prolongement
de farès sellette le personnage que
j'aime le plus dans mon livre leur
apprécié cet affreux parce que des
choses déjà les dires ne regrettez pas
tout quand je raconte pas tout les
choses s'enveniment c'est pas le mot
mais une pièce de gradation dans les
accotements et c'est volontaire et cet
affreux mais c'est la réalité il faut
savoir dans ces années 90 surtout autour
des années 96 97
il ya des villages qu'il ya des gens qui
ont été égorgés et des fois à plusieurs
centaines d'individus pendant pendant
une nuit
c'est une horreur ce que vit ce que vit
ce pauvre pays mais ce que vous écrivez
la waste of de sol oui ça existe encore
aujourd'hui s'est dit encore aujourd'hui
ça existe aujourd'hui je vais dire tout
à fait lourd tout à fait on voit des
gens qui sont décapités la saison tu es
armand plus tard alors devant une caméra
tout à fait les villages qui sont boulet
donc je veux dire même ce qui s'est
passé et continuité m malheureux à dire
une continuité tout en horreur de la
tâche et c'est pour ça je vous dis que
c'était un préambule de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui un peu ce qui se passe en
algérie
bon cela dit vous aimez bien les
histoires famille la façade dernière
c'était dans l'île dans votre c'était
c'était quelque chose de beaucoup plus
intime c'est un récit autobiographique
mais là aussi elles comme amélie sort au
début c'est vrai c'est vrai mais je
voudrais je voudrais que les que les
gens comprennent que moi moi j'ai connu
enfant in algeri vraiment extraordinaire
où les gens vraiment vivez les uns à
côté des autres
il y avait il y avait une très grande
tolérance à l'époque et malheureusement
dans les années dans les décennies qui
ont suivi tous les problèmes que connaît
que connaît ce pays c'est une réalité
c'est quelque chose de triste c'est un
peuple qui souffrent malgré tout et
pourtant c'est un peuple extraordinaire
car énormément d'atouts qui est un
peuple à l'origine extrêmement
extrêmement chaleureux extrêmement
convivial c'est terrible de vie
milieu de la peur de mourir et de la
corruption c'est terrible ce que vit ce
peuple alors tu as d'ailleurs je crois
que je les lui ben je suis pas certain à
la page 32 et 33 donc c'est la
radicalisation oui c'est ça alger
lakhdar pratiquer sa foi de manière
intense par amour authentique etc etc
si vous écrivez un peu plus dès cet
instant et s'engagea très vite et de
manière presque naturelle dans un parti
religieux dans le radicalisme et les
adhésions massives provoquées dans le
pays quelques inquiétudes et faisait
crème sur le fait ou tard le retour de
bâton tout à fait aux 91 des élections
législatives
amen le parti parti un parti religieux
et dans les semaines qui suivent même
pas dans les jours qui ont suivi les
élections ont été annulées
et il ya eu donc une sorte de coup
d'état civil en quelque sorte parce que
le pouvoir de l'époque ne voyaient pas
d'un bon oeil ses 7,7 s'étaler ce
comment dire cet engagement vers un
système religieux vers une théocratie
alors on va vous poser la question que
je pose habituellement donc aux gens qui
viennent ici puisque tout à l'heure
c'est une fête qui est une qui est très
prolixe et or vous aussi vous êtes en
préparation d'un autre roman c'est à
dire que gégé attends j'ai écrit un
recueil de poésie et et d'ailleurs c'est
avec mon ami photographe jean rémy nous
avons fait une sorte de correspondance
entre mais poésie ses photographies lui
ces photographies sont sur l'océan
indien et moi mais poésie sont universal
en quelque sorte et on a essayé de
trouver des correspondances mais
j'attends éventuellement de savoir si un
éditeur va nous publié voilà mes mais
j'ai d'autres idées de dormans et je ne
les crains pas sur l'algérie les
prochains livres à voile a devancé je
vais vous poser d'actes non pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout mais cgt je suis
extrêmement triste de ce qui se passe
dans le monde cette intolérance ou
croissante savez je suis enseignant et
et tous les jours j'ai devant moi des
gens qui sont en recul et multicolore
multi religieux ou pas religieux du tout
pas porte et c'est extraordinaire ce qui
se passe est une réelle harmonie entre
les élèves
c'est vrai que la réunion pour moi c'est
un sanctuaire et je suis triste de voir
qu'en dehors la réunion et qu'il ya une
intolérance qui est grand si
grandissante
mais cette intolérance cette tolérance
qu'à la réunion penser qu'elle est
toujours d'actualité parce que de temps
en temps on sent quand même je pense
très miss poutine nous transpercer le
mur on sent que l'on veut dire quoi en
ciel gronde sociale met les autres c'est
à nous tous les ans
données avérées voulait pas trop
d'accord mou tollé mais pas trop le mot
ans qui vit à combien pas m'aimer fun
fait avec quoi laquelle m'embêterait la
loi met donc et il aurait les tolérants
n'aime pas ça mais il ne vient pas et
tous les vestiaires les peaux cris - -
et le maoût les ventes radio en france
et veut dire mais pas trop d'accord mais
avec quoi c'est ce qui nous fait son
entrée dans le conseil désire ski -
mondiaux des métaux les bons mais pas
tous les 20 millièmes tout demoun où ils
n'aiment pas ça a même pas ça devienne
passa donc pas donné à moi il ya un mot
que je déteste ces intolérance non mais
tous les rôles et valérie vocales
peuvent alors donner à mes mandats
kouame mitoyenneté avec quoi alors que
les rares le dictionnaire indiquent
qu'ils manifestent de la tolérance vous
avec sachez monsieur veut compréhensif
indulgent voilà un des synonymes qui a
pour tolérant bien alors donc eu en tout
cas je suis je me sens vraiment bien
calé lecture justement qui préserve 7,7
harmonique en a entre nous sur cette île
c'est une chose qui est extraordinaire
c'est le métissage
alors là pas de prochain livre donc des
de la poésie pour cette année en
condition de retrouver un gg d'autres
pourraient conditions trouver un éditeur
exactement et on sait à peu près ce
qu'il y aura dans ses poésies oui oui
je j'ai écrit j'ai écrit des poésies sur
j'écris une poésie sur la réunion ii
j'ai écrit une poésie sur madagascar et
puis et puis bon c'est ce recueil
j'allais appeler mes automnale où ça
veut dire quoi ça c'est à dire si
j'avais su à cette époque de ma vie
d'accord vous êtes à mes automne à la
fumée automnale je prends mon
dictionnaire faut que je trouve là